das ist ein Film über die Macht der
Zentralbanken
Zentralbanken haben die Macht
wirtschaftliche politische und soziale
Veränderungen zu bewirken
und so gehen Sie dabei vor
Pearl Harbor siebter 1941
[Musik]
dieser Film basiert auf einem Buch von
Professor Richard Werner
[Musik]
lang lebe die kaiserliche Armee
die Prinzen des Yen
Zentralbanken und die Transformation der
Wirtschaft
[Musik]
ich gelobe Treue zur Flagge der
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
[Musik]
die Atombombe
wir werden um 9:30 Uhr in Yokohama
ankommen
die ausschiffungspriorität richtet sich
nach dem ausschiffungszeitplan
[Musik]
general Douglas general Douglas
MacArthur traf am 30 August 1945 auf dem
marineflugplatz Azubi in der Nähe von
Yokohama ein
Asia Merch von mir sehr klar als er aus
seinem Flugzeug stieg blieb er oben an
der Treppe stehen steckte eine Hand in
die Hüfttasche spahnte den Kiefer um
seine maiskolbenpfeife und betrachtete
das eroberte Land
Wispel wurde mehrmals wiederholt damit
alle Pressefotografen eine gute Aufnahme
machen konnten
die Demokratie sollte dem japanischen
Volk eingeimpft werden als hätte es noch
nie von etwas anderem gehört
unser Problem liegt im Kopf der Japaner
diese Köpfe können wie unsere gute oder
schlechte Dinge tun abhängig von der Art
die Ideen die in sie hineingelegt werden
[Musik]
Stücke in denen loyale Samurai auftreten
wurden verboten oder stark zensiert
ebenso wie Bücher und Filme über die
Bombardierung von Hiroshima und Nagasaki
satirische Karikaturen über McArthur und
die Erwähnung der besatzungssensor waren
strengstens untersagt
die Kommission befindet sich
verschuldigt im Sinne der Anklage und
verurteilt sie zum Tode durch den
strangt sich bei der Kommission für den
fairen Verlauf seines Prozesses
der damalige Premierminister im
Pazifikkrieg general Toyo sagte während
seines Prozesses keiner dieser Japaner
würde es wagen gegen den Willen des
Kaisers zu handeln
wurde sofort abgebrochen und eine Woche
später erklärte Toyo pflichtbewusst der
Kaiser habe den Frieden immer geliebt
und gewollt
der die offizielle Verantwortung für die
Führung des Krieges übernahm und alles
tat um seinen Kaiser zu entlasten
na klar
bemerkte später vor dem US-Senat dass
sich die Japaner in Bezug auf die
moderne Zivilisation wie ein zwölf Jahre
alter Junge verhielten
[Musik]
du interessierst dich für das Unbekannte
das mysteriöse das Unerklärliche deshalb
bist du hier
als der Krieg vorbei war hatten sich die
kreditbücher der Banken verschlechtert
bei den Vermögenswerten der Banken
handelte es sich hauptsächlich um
Kriegsanleihen und Kredite an zerstörte
Industrien damit war der gesamte
Bankensektor praktisch bankrott
this problem muss easy Soul dieses
Problem konnte von der japanischen
Zentralbank leicht gelöst werden sie
musste nur die faulen Papiere des
Bankensektors mit neu geschaffenen
Reserven aufkaufen und ihnen gutes Geld
für oft wertlose Vermögenswerte geben
die ersten beiden Zentralbank
Gouverneure der Nachkriegszeit wurden
von der amerikanischen Besatzungsmacht
ernannti wurde zum ersten Nachkriegs
Gouverneur der japanischen Zentralbank
ernannt doch kurz nach seinem
Amtsantritt wurde er von der
Staatsanwaltschaft wegen
Kriegsverbrechen angeklagt und musste
zurücktreten
wenn in nighting fifty one nach einer
allgemeinen Amnestie für mutmaßliche
Kriegsverbrecher die öffentliche Ämter
bekleideten wurde er 1951 zum
Botschafter in den Vereinigten Staaten
ernannt als er von seinem Botschafter
Posten im Jahr 1954 abtrat wurde eraki
erneut zum Gouverneur der Zentralbank
ernannt
after the ninety nach der Amnestie für
Kriegsverbrecher im Jahr 1951 wurde ein
Großteil der japanischen
kriegsbürokraten wieder in ihre
Positionen aus der Kriegszeit versetzt
dazu gehörten Politiker aus der
Kriegszeit und die meisten Bürokraten
des Innenministeriums die für die
Gedankenpolizei zuständig gewesen waren
und von denen einige in das
Bildungsministerium wechselten
Japan ist der Schlüssel zum Schicksal
des fernen Ostens noch einmal zum
zweiten Mal während des Vormarsches der
modernen Geschichte haben diese Worte
dringende Notwendigkeit
um Unruhen auf dem Lande zu verhindern
die den Kommunisten in China in die
Hände spielten leiteten die Amerikaner
die Umverteilung von Land von
Großgrundbesitzern an ihre Pächter ein
die kapitalistische Elite Japans die
sogenannte seibazoo wurde wegen ihrer
Unterstützung eines verbrecherischen
Krieges gesäubert und von weiteren
geschäftlichen Aktivitäten
ausgeschlossen
im Grunde genommen hat die US-Besatzung
die faschistische Politik der 30er Jahre
die die Reform faschistischen Bürokraten
während des Krieges nicht umsetzen
konnten zu Ende geführt wie die
Landreform und die sei wahr zu Politik
ja es ist eine sehr seltsame Begegnung
von japanischen kriegsfaschisten und
amerikanischen
[Musik]
das Parlament sitzt von japansenator und
Repräsentantenhaus
den Japan randalierten fanatische
Studenten und linke Gruppen tagelang um
den gegenseitigen verteidigungsvertrag
mit Amerika zu verhindern die
sozialistischen Abgeordneten
inszenierten einen Aufstand im Parlament
die Polizei vertrieb sie um die Ordnung
wiederherzustellen
[Applaus]
der Redner wurde auf das Podium getragen
und rief die Sitzung in der der Vertrag
angenommen wurde zur Ordnung
den 1957 1957 wurde der ehemalige
Kriegsverbrecher der Klasse A Kishi
nobuzuka Premierminister von Japan
se der war während des Krieges
generatorius Minister verhandel und
Industrie gewesen dessen
Zuständigkeitsbereich von Munition bis
zur Sklavenarbeit reichte
wow Hitlers
wo time während Hitlers
kriegswirtschaftsminister Albert Speer
in Berlin-Spandau im Gefängnis saß war
sein japanischer Gegenpart
Ministerpräsident des Landes
nach dem Krieg ein Verfechter der
Demokratie wurde hatte er sich vor und
während des Krieges als
Nationalsozialist bezeichnet
mit dem Geld von Verbrecher sind die
Karten Industrieunternehmen und CIA
Schmiergeldern baute Kishi die liberald
Demokratische Partei zu einem mächtigen
politischen Apparat aus
in Japan in Japan stammten viele der
wichtigen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Führer der Nachkriegszeit
aus einer elitären Gruppe von Bürokraten
aus der Kriegszeit die Japan in den
Krieg getrieben hatten
die liberal demokratische Partei blieb
fast 40 Jahre lang an der Macht
willkommen zu hause auf japanisch für
diese amerikanischen Soldaten nach einem
Einsatz in Korea kehren sie zu ihrem
Stützpunkt in Japan zurück wo sie kurz
zuvor noch als Besatzungstruppen
stationiert waren und wie kehren sie
zurück wie werden sie von den Menschen
empfangen deren Land sie besetzen nicht
als Oberherren nicht als Feinde nicht
als Männer denen man misstraut die man
fürchtet und denen man es übel nimmt
sondern als Freunde
[Musik]
in türkis centralabo im zentralen
Tokyoter Stadtteil chioda hatte das
Finanzministerium seinen Sitz von hier
aus kontrollierte das Ministerium die
meisten Bereiche der japanischen
Wirtschaft
das Finanzministerium war das mächtigste
Ministerium und die Zentralbank musste
dem Finanzministerium Berichterstatten
Ministerium der Ernte des
Finanzministeriums ernteten Ehrfurcht
und Respekt und ehemalige
Ministerialbeamte erhielten
einflussreiche Posten als Leiter
öffentlicher und privater Einrichtungen
[Musik]
in einem Bereich hatte das Ministerium
jedoch keine tatsächliche Kontrolle und
zwar über den Umfang der Kreditschöpfung
und deren Zuteilung über die von der
Bank of Japan der japanischen
Zentralbank entschieden wurde
sie sagten dem Finanzministerium und der
Öffentlichkeit und den Journalisten wir
betreiben Geldpolitik über den Leitzins
und sie ließen das Finanzministerium
über ihre Zinspolitik bestimmen aber die
Herrschaft wurde nicht über die
Zinspolitik erreicht sondern über die
Geldmenge
window guidance ein Verfahren in dem
eine Zentralbank den Geschäftsbanken
Quoten für das Kreditwachstum und die
Kreditvergabe vorgibt
[Musik]
es funktioniert folgendermaßen man nennt
es Windows die japanische Zentralbank
hat den Banken einfach gesagt wie viel
sie im kommenden Quartal verleihen
müssen und an welchen Wirtschaftssektor
einzelnen Banken vierteljährlich
Anweisungen über die Höhe der Kredite
und darüber welchen Industriezweigen sie
zuzuordnen waren alle Kredite wurden
nach Sektoren und Teilsektoren
aufgeschlüsselt und die großkreditnehmer
mussten namentlich aufgeführt werden
die Zentralbank konnte entscheiden
welche Projekte gefördert und welche
ausgebremst werden sollten indem sie
diktierte an wen und wofür die Banken
Kredite vergeben konnten
das war das System der Kriegswirtschaft
angepasst an die Produktion von
Konsumgütern
die 95 Millionen Einwohner Japans
genießen heute einen nationales
Einkommen das nur von den Vereinigten
Staaten und den Wohlhaben deren Nationen
Westeuropas übertroffen wird
es ist kein gutes System für
Kapitalisten aber für die Bevölkerung
hat es eine Menge Reichtum geschaffen
eine sehr gleichmäßige Einkommens und
Vermögensverteilung ein sehr hohes
Wachstum und eine sehr schnelle
Steigerung der Lebensqualität und des
Lebensstandards
allein im Jahr 1959 wuchs die Wirtschaft
um 17 Prozent das System der
Kriegswirtschaft hatte jedoch zur Folge
das ganze Industriezweige nicht um
Gewinne sondern um Marktanteile
konkurrierten
die Unternehmen kämpften bis zum
bankrottomarktanteile
dieses Phänomen wurde bald erkannt und
als überhöhter Wettbewerb bezeichnet die
Lösung war die Bildung von expliziten
oder impliziten
in the banking Sekte im Bankensektor
fungierte die window guidance als
Kontrollmechanismus da die japanische
Zentralbank die Anzahl und den Wert der
von den Banken vergebenen Kredite
vorgeben konnte
also result infolgedessen änderte sich
die Rangordnung der Banken in der
Nachkriegszeit nie außer nach Fusionen
ein Banker sagte ohne die Windows würden
wir bis zum Harakiri miteinander kämpfen
das Leistungsbilanzdefizit der USA
steigt auf den höchsten Stand seit 9
Jahren das Ausmaß des Anstiegs hat viele
Ökonomen überrascht
world während Kartelle den Wettbewerb
innerhalb Japans kontrollierten gab es
solche Grenzen nicht wenn es um
internationale Märkte ging
japanische Konzerne wurden bald auf
vielen Märkten der Welt dominant
in America in Amerika wurden formelle
Anhörungen im Kongress abgehalten
Untertiteln wie Produktivität Lektionen
für Amerika
[Musik]
leading economic furious führende
Wirtschaftstheorien besagen dass nur
freie Märkte zum Erfolg führen können
doch Japan ist innerhalb von Jahrzehnten
zur zweitgrößten Volkswirtschaft der
Welt aufgestiegen ohne sich nur auf die
unsichtbare Hand der freien Märkte zu
verlassen
ja economy Japans nachkriegswirtschaft
war eine vollständig mobilisierte
Kriegswirtschaft wobei die Produktion
von Waffen auf Konsumgüter umgestellt
wurde
es ist besser für die japanische
Zentralbank nicht aufzufallen und so
still zu sein wie der Wald eines
ländlichen Schreins
pisatuishimada Gouverneur der
japanischen Zentralbank von 1946 bis 54
japanische Zentralbank als Meisterin der
freien Märkte präsentierte galt die
Windows als Peinlichkeit
inoffiziellen Veröffentlichungen wurde
sie entweder nicht erwähnt oder ihre
Rolle heruntergespielt indem die
kreditkontrollen als freiwillig
bezeichnet wurden
wann immer sich das Finanzministerium
über die Kreditvergabepolitik der
japanischen Zentralbank erkundigte
ließen sich die Mitarbeiter der
japanischen Zentralbank auf komplexe
Diskussionen voller Fachjargon ein um
den Prozess für Laien um durchschaubar
zu machen
Ende November 1965 im november 1965 kam
die erste Serie japanischer
Staatsanleihen auf den Markt von nun an
übten die Politiker wenn Sie mehr Geld
ausgeben wollten nicht mehr Druck auf
die Zentralbank sondern auf das
Finanzministerium aus das Ministerium
würde also letztlich die Aufsicht über
einen immer größer werdenden
staatsschuldenberg führen
[Musik]
die 1980er Jahre waren eine Ehre der
finanziellen Deregulierung in der
industrialisierten Welt die meisten
Industrieländer hoben ihre
Beschränkungen für den Kapitalverkehr
auf
in Japan in Japan forderte ein
ehemaliger Gouverneur der japanischen
Zentralbank einen Fünfjahresplan für die
Umgestaltung und Liberalisierung der
japanischen Wirtschaft
wenn in 196 im Jahr 1986 schlug die
beratende Gruppe für die wirtschaftliche
Umstrukturierung unter der Leitung des
ehemaligen Gouverneurs der japanischen
Zentralbank Hero maycava einen auf 10
Jahre angelegten wirtschaftsreformplan
vor mit dem der Lebensstandard der
Japaner an den des Westens angeglichen
werden sollte
[Musik]
in dem Vorschlag heißt es für Japan ist
jetzt die Zeit gekommen einen
historischen Wandel in seiner
traditionellen Wirtschaftspolitik und
seinem Lebensstil vorzunehmen
ohne diesen Wandel kann es keine weitere
Entwicklung für Japan geben
der Bericht las sich wie ein
Wunschzettel der US-Handels Unterhändler
er begann mit Forderungen nach einer
Verwaltungsreform und der Abschaffung
bürokratischer Befugnisse das Ziel war
die Umgestaltung der gesamten Politik
die Abschaffung des
kriegswirtschaftssystems und die
Einführung einer freien Marktwirtschaft
nach amerikanischem Vorbild
diejenigen Mitglieder der Beratergruppe
die eine abweichende Meinung äußerten
wurden von ihren Aufgaben entbunden
die Berichte in der Presse waren sehr
kritisch beobachte erkannten den
radikalen Charakter des Plans er schien
viel zu ehrgeizig er forderte eine
umfassende Revolution aller Teile des
japanischen wirtschaftlichen politischen
und sozialen Systems
[Musik]
obwohl der Bericht klar formulierte was
gewollt war Schwieger sich peinlich
darüber aus wie diese Ziele erreicht
werden sollten der einzige Hinweis der
im Bericht versteckt war lautete bei der
Umsetzung dieser Empfehlungen kommt der
Steuer- und Geldpolitik eine wichtige
Rolle zu signific
[Musik]
die japanische Zentralbank hat immer
gesagt dass das japanische System
abgeschafft werden sollte es sollte
einfach komplett abgeschafft werden und
der Kapitalismus nach amerikanischem
Vorbild sollte eingeführt werden ob sie
damit einverstanden sind oder nicht ist
eine ganz andere Frage aber die
Zentralbank ist auf jeden Fall der
Meinung dass es abgeschafft werden
sollte die nächste Frage ist nun wie man
das anstellen soll das Finanzministerium
hat die meiste Zeit der Nachkriegszeit
rechtlich die Kontrolle gehabt wir haben
eingefahrene bürokratische Strukturen
Politiker und all diese Kartelle und so
weiter das war das alte System nun lernt
die Geschichte dass sich ein System nur
dann grundlegend ändert wenn es eine
Krise gibt
die Kommission schlug vor dass die
Geldpolitik zur Förderung einer
historischen Krise eingesetzt werden
sollte die groß genug ist um die
Interessen des Finanzministeriums der
Politiker und der japanischen
Unternehmen zu überwinden
every System in jedem System gibt es
Gruppen die davon profitieren und daher
nicht den Wunsch haben es zu ändern es
gibt wahrscheinlich kein Land auf der
Welt das sein wirtschaftliches soziales
und politisches System ohne eine Krise
in nennenswerter Weise verändert hat
es ist die Krise die die Bürger und
Interessensgruppen von der Notwendigkeit
eines Wandels überzeugt
nun wie kann man das erreichen man
braucht eine Krise und der beste Weg sie
zu erzeugen ist eine Blase denn so hält
eine niemand auf
[Musik]
the Bank of Japan die japanische
Zentralbank begann die Quoten für die
Vergabe von schaufensterkrediten
deutlich zu erhöhen in den späten 1980er
Jahren lagen die durchschnittlichen
jährlichen kreditwachstumsquoten bei
fast 15 Prozent ein städtischer Banker
bemerkte später während der
Spekulationsblase wollten wir nur eine
bestimmte Anzahl von Krediten erhöhen
aber die japanische Zentralbank wollte
dass wir mehr schaffen
junge Leute in ihren 20ern und 30ern
konnten sich auch mit bescheidenen
Gehältern zweite und dritt Wohnungen
kaufen
nicht nur zu einem Immobilienboom
sondern auch zu einem Boom auf dem
Aktienmarkt
zwischen 1985 und 1989 stiegen die
Aktien um 240% und die Grundstückspreise
um 245%
[Musik]
weil sie Ende the 80s Ende der 80er
Jahre war der Wert des Gartens der den
Kaiserpalast im Zentrum Tokios umgibt so
viel wert wie der gesamte Staat
Kalifornien
[Musik]
obwohl Japan nur ein 26 der Größe der
Vereinigten Staaten hat wurde sein Grund
und Boden mit dem Vierfachen des Wertes
der Vereinigten Staaten bewertet
[Musik]
the market Valley der Marktwert eines
einzigen der 23 Bezirke von Tokio der
Zentrale Bezirk chioda überstieg den
Wert von ganz Kanada
Economist Wirtschaftswissenschaftler die
darauf trainiert sind an Marktergebnisse
zu glauben versuchten die hohen
Grundstückspreise zu rechtfertigen
einige glaubten dass die Grundstücks
Knappheit der Grund sei
shining
Geschäftsviertel entstanden glänzende
neue firmenzen der Arbeitsmarkt boomte
so sehr dass ein ernsthafter Mangel an
Arbeitskräften befürchtet wurde
[Musik]
die Unternehmen begannen Studenten im
letzten Studienjahr zu teuren Reisen in
Ferienorte einzuladen um sie zu einer
Anstellung zu bewegen
[Musik]
die Politiker liebten es das
Finanzministerium liebte es die
Steuereinnahmen stiegen die Unternehmen
liebten es alles war wunderbar in der
bubblehrer
jeder Tag war wie ein Fest wie ein
Mädchen wurden ausgeführt und alles
wurde immer von den Jungs und den Chefs
bezahlt niemand hat öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel benutzt um nach Hause zu
kommen wir haben immer ein Taxi genommen
[Musik]
angesichts des unaufhaltsamen Anstiegs
der Vermögens und Aktienkurse konnten
selbst traditionelle Hersteller der
Versuchung nicht widerstehen sich an den
Märkten zu versuchen bald bauten sie
ihre Finanz und treasure-abteilungen aus
um die Spekulationen selbst in die Hand
zu nehmen
wie es company hat diese Hedgefonds der
Unternehmen bekannt als sei-tech nutzten
geliehenes Geld um mit Immobilien und
Aktien zu spekulieren
der Wahnsinn nahm solche Ausmaße an dass
viele führende Hersteller wie zum
Beispiel der Autohersteller Nissan mehr
Geld mit spekulativen Investitionen als
mit der Produktion von Autos verdienten
es wurden buchstäblich Tausende von
Artikeln über das neue japanische
Wirtschaftswunder geschrieben
bei Economist viele
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler gaben an dass
die hohe und steigende Produktivität die
beeindruckende Leistung der japanischen
Wirtschaft erklärt
Management Bücher über japanische
Management-Techniken wurden zu
internationalen Bestsellern westliche
Geschäftsleute lasen Traktate aus dem 17
Jahrhundert über Samurai Strategien
[Musik]
in reality in Wirklichkeit hatte Japans
herausragende Leistungen in den 1980er
Jahren wenig mit Management Techniken zu
tun anstatt die Kreditvergabe zu
begrenzen und zu steuern wurde die
schaufensterpolitik dazu genutzt eine
riesige Blase zu erzeugend
ich habe Nachforschungen angestellt und
Beamte der japanischen Zentralbank und
Banker beide Seiten auf Tonband befragt
das Ergebnis war dass die japanische
Zentralbank ihre informelle Beratung
fortsetzte tatsächlich war es die
japanische Zentralbank die die Banken
dazu zwang ihre Kreditvergabe so stark
zu erhöhen
die japanische Zentralbank wusste dass
die einzige Möglichkeit für die Banken
ihre kreditquoten zu erfüllen darin
bestand die unproduktive Kreditvergabe
auszuweiten mit den Worten eines
Bankangestellten wenn es keine Nachfrage
nach Krediten von risikoarmen
Kreditnehmern gibt und wie die Quote
ausschöpfen wollen wird das Risiko noch
größer
einer Banker ist ein anderer Banker wird
mit den Worten zitiert dass ein
Nebeneffekt der Regel der Windows bei
der Kreditvergabe darin bestand dass die
Banken die Kreditvergabe auch dann
erhöhten wenn es keine Kredit Nachfrage
gab
like oh wie alle Blasen wurde auch die
japanische Blase einfach durch die
rasche Geldschöpfung des Bankensystems
angeheizt
between nineteen ETCS zwischen 1986 und
leitetei die bankenabteilung der
japanischen Zentralbank die für die
Quoten für die Windows zuständig war
when von einem Journalisten gefragt
wurde die Kreditaufnahme nimmt schnell
zu haben sie nicht die Absicht den Harn
bei den Bankkrediten zuzudrehen
antwortete er da die konsequente Politik
der geldpolitischen Lockerung
fortgesetzt wird würde eine quantitative
Kontrolle der Bankkredite einen
Widerspruch in sich darstellen daher
haben wir nicht die Absicht eine
quantitative Straffung durchzuführen
da die strukturelle Anpassung der
Wirtschaft schon seit geraumer Zeit
andauert werden die internationalen
Ungleichgewichte angegangen die
Geldpolitik unterstützt dies so dass wir
die Verantwortung haben die lockere
Geldpolitik so lange wie möglich
vorzusetzen daher ist es nur natürlich
dass die Bankkredite ausgeweitet werden
warum haben die Banken so viel Geld
verdient weil sie durch die Anweisung
der japanischen Zentralbank dazu
gezwungen wurden
normalerweise wählen die Banken ihre
Kunden aus einer großen Anzahl von
kreditantragsstellern aus und lehnen
einen erheblichen Prozentsatz ab
bartrum 19 doch ab 1987 hatte sich das
Blatt gewendet es waren die Banker die
aggressiv vom potenzielle Kunden Waben
es gibt viele Anekdoten darüber wie die
Banken Kredite zu günstigen Zinssätzen
anboten und Kunden wie Straßenhändler
umworben haben
die Banken ermutigten die Menschen sich
Geld zu leihen wenn zum Beispiel ein
frisch verheiratetes Paar ein Haus
kaufen wollte boten ihnen die Banken den
doppelten Betrag den sie verlangten
den Grundstückswert zunehmend überhöht
ein so dass das tatsächliche Verhältnis
von Grundstückswert zu Kredit oft auf
300% oder mehr Anstieg
für die Öffentlichkeit war dies ein
seltsames Phänomen die Leute nannten es
bald Geld Überschuss nur
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Analysten und
diejenigen die an den Finanzmärkten oder
für Immobilienfirmen Arbeiten wussten es
besser
Vedes
sie lehnten solche vereinfachenden
Analysen ab sie behaupteten dass der
Anstieg der Grundstückspreise weitaus
kompliziertere Gründe hätte als nur
einen geldüberschuss gewöhnliche
Menschen verstanden einfach nicht die
Feinheiten der modernen
finanztechnologie
wenn ein Land zu viel Geld schafft
fließt ein Teil dieses Geldes in Form
von Investitionen ins Ausland ab in den
80er Jahren vervielfachten sich die
japanischen Kapitalströme von einem
netto-zufluss von mehr als 2 Milliarden
Dollar im Jahr 1980 auf einen Abfluss
von 132 Milliarden Dollar im Jahr 1986
Vermögenswerte darunter Kunstgegenstände
und andere Wertgegenstände in der ganzen
Welt wurden zum Ziel japanischer Käufer
es gab hochkarätige Käufe wie das
Rockefeller Center Columbia Pictures und
in Pebble Beach golf course
japanes money japanische Gelder kauften
sage und schreibe 75% aller 1986
versteigerten US-Staatsanleihen
aber es ist nicht einfach für ein Land
einfach Geld zu drucken und dann auf
eine Einkaufstour durch die Welt zu
gehen Japan war dazu in der Lage weil
die Märkte seine Währung nicht abwerten
der Wert der einzelnen Währungen wird
von Devisenhändlern festgelegt wenn die
traditionellen Indikatoren auf die die
Devisenhändler achten die übermäßige
Geldschöpfung in den betreffenden Land
nicht anzeigen kann es funktionieren
große Geldmengen zu schaffen und zu
versuchen sie in ausländische Währung
umzutauschen
Japan hatte denselben Trick angewandt
wie die Vereinigten Staaten in den
1950er und 1960er Jahren als die
US-Banken exzessiv Dollars schufen
copy America die amerikanischen
Unternehmen nutzten dieses heiße Geld um
europäische Unternehmen aufzukaufen
während die Vereinigten Staaten durch
den Goldstandard des Dollars gedeckt
waren bestand Japans Deckung in einem
erheblichen Handelsüberschuss
ein nicht bip-basierter Kredit ein
Kredit der nicht für die Produktion von
Waren oder Dienstleistungen verwendet
wird
ein early wohning indicate ein
Frühwarnindikator für die Entstehung
eines systemischen Risikos im
Bankensystem ist das Verhältnis von
Krediten für nicht bip-basierte
Transaktionen zu den gesamtkrediten
wish Richard in den meisten Ländern die
Anschließen von einer Bankenkrise
heimgesucht werden steigt dieses
Verhältnis deutlich an
es war derselbe Prozess der die
Hypothekenkredite und den Boom der
Immobilienpreise in den Vereinigten
Staaten und dem Vereinigten Königreich
in den 1980er und 2000er jahreneinste
der selbe Prozess führte auch zu den
goldenen Zwanzigern in den 1920er Jahren
vergaben die Banken in den USA Kredite
mit Aktien als Sicherheiten das Prinzip
bleibt dasselbe da jede Bank den
Aktienkurs als gegeben ansah schuf sie
neues Geld
je mehr Geld auf dem Aktienmarkt war
desto mehr mussten die Aktienkurse
steigen jede Bank hielt es für
Sicherheit einen bestimmten Prozentsatz
des aktienwerts als Sicherheit zu
akzeptieren aber die Aktionen aller
Banken zusammentrieben den Gesamtmarkt
in die Höhe
in Japan in Japan steht das gesamte
Grundvermögen des privaten Sektors von
14,2 Billionen Yen im Jahr 1969 auf 2000
Billionen Yen im Jahr 1989
seiner ersten Pressekonferenz als 26
Gouverneur der japanischen Zentralbank
im Jahr 1989 sagte yasushimeno da die
lockere Geldpolitik das Problem des
Anstiegs der Grundstückspreise
verursacht habe werde die Kreditvergabe
im Zusammenhang mit Immobilien nun
eingeschränkt
er sah sich um sah die Blase die
steigenden Vermögenspreise die immer
größer werdende Kluft zwischen Arm und
Reich das müssen wir stoppen sein Name
war mirino und er war ein Held in der
Presse weil er gegen diese dumme
Geldpolitik kämpfte tatsache ist jedoch
dass er in der Zeit der Blase
stellvertretender Gouverneur und für die
Entstehung der Blase verantwortlich war
[Musik]
plötzlich stiegen die Grundstücks und
Vermögenspreise nicht mehr allein im
Jahr 1990 brachte Aktienmarkt um 32% ein
[Musik]
wenn Angelina 1991 dann im Juli 1991
wurde die window guidance abgeschafft
dies kam für die Verantwortlichen der
japanischen Zentralbank selbst
überraschend die Banker waren nahezu
hilflos sie beklagten sich darüber dass
sie nicht mehr wussten wie sie ihre
kreditvergabepläne erstellen sollten
wenn in der Vergangenheit eine bestimmte
Filiale sagte dass sie gerne mehr
Kredite vergeben würde antworteten sie
dass die Quote für die window Guardians
ausgeschöpft sein
jetzt konnten sie das nicht mehr tun
[Musik]
als banks beginnt als die Banken
erkannten dass der Großteil der 99
Billionen Yen an Bubble Krediten
wahrscheinlich scheitern würde wurden
sie so ängstlich dass sie nicht nur die
Kreditvergabe an Spekulanten einstellten
sondern auch die Kreditvergabe an alle
anderen
für Japan bevor die Börse Sankt am
Montag auf den niedrigsten Stand seit
über zwei Jahren der Zusammenbruch eines
der größten Lebensmittelhändler Japans
in der vergangenen Woche war der 9 eines
börsennotierten Unternehmens in diesem
Jahr
morgen 5 Millionen Japanese los mehr als
5 Millionen Japaner verloren ihre Arbeit
und fanden keine andere Beschäftigung
suicide Selbstmord wurde zur häufigsten
Todesursache bei Männern im Alter
zwischen 20 und 44 Jahren
[Musik]
die Zeitungen berichteten fast täglich
über Menschen die sich erhängten oder
verschwanden
[Musik]
zwischen 1990 und 2003 fiel der
Aktienmarkt um 80 Prozent die
Grundstückspreise in den Großstädten
fiel nun bis zu 84 Prozent einige
Ökonomen Schienen erleichtert zu sein
[Musik]
Beweis dafür dass Japans
Wirtschaftssystem doch nicht so
erfolgreich war
unterdessen sagte der Gouverneur der
japanischen Zentralbank die assujimo das
sich dank dieser Rezession jeder der
Notwendigkeit einer wirtschaftlichen
Umgestaltung bewusst wird Transformation
[Musik]
das Finanzministerium das die Zinssätze
für das wichtigste politische Instrument
hielt übte Druck auf die Zentralbank aus
die Zinssätze zu senken bis der
offizielle Zinssatz 0,1% erreichte
meist Economist die meisten
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler sagten eine
wirtschaftliche Erholung voraus
[Musik]
Bart des bite trotz der häufigen
Behauptungen in der Finanzpresse und von
den Zentralbanken das niedrigere Zinsen
das Wachstum ankurbeln und höhere Zinsen
das Wachstum bremsen gibt es keine
empirischen Belege für diesen
Zusammenhang
[Musik]
American business manager japanische und
amerikanische Geschäftsleute treffen
sich hier mit einem Plädoyer der
japanischen Unternehmen für eine
niedrigeren Yen nur sechs Prozent der
japanischen Exporteure können bei einem
Dollarkurs von weniger als 100 Yen
Gewinne erzielen im Durchschnitt müssen
Sie die amerikanische Währung auf über
117 Yen anheben um die Gewinnschwelle zu
erreichen the Ministry of Finance das
Finanzministerium Party Zentralbank
große Mengen an Yen zu verkaufen und
US-Dollar zu kaufen damit der
Wechselkurs des jensinken und die
Exporte steigen würden
wir alle wissen dass die beiden das
Finanzministerium und die Zentralbank
nicht gut miteinander auskommen und was
diesen Monat wieder passiert ist ist das
die Zentralbank ihrer eigenen
Interventionen sterilisiert hat um genau
zu sein die Interventionen die vom
Finanzministerium angeordnet wurden
das Finanzministerium weist die
japanische Zentralbank an
US-Staatsanleihen im Wert von etwa 20
Milliarden zu kaufen doch die japanische
Zentralbank sterilisiert dies das heißt
sie entzieht der Wirtschaft Geld um
diesen Kauf zu finanzieren die meisten
Forscher sind sich einig dass
sterilisierte Devisenmarkt
Interventionen nicht funktionieren die
Zentralbank sterilisiert erneut deshalb
funktioniert es nicht deshalb ist der
Jens stark geblieben
[Musik]
keine Zentralbank kann Geld aus der
Wirtschaft abziehen indem sie ihre
Vermögenswerte verkauft genauso wie sie
der Wirtschaft Geld zu führen kann indem
sie Vermögenswerte kauft
when central banks bei and cell asset
wenn Zentralbanken Vermögenswerte kaufen
und verkaufen erhöhen oder verringern
sie die in der Wirtschaft zirkulierende
Geldmenge
die Beamten der japanischen Zentralbank
ignorierten dies und behaupteten
stattdessen dass dieser Strukturwandel
oder diese Reform kurzfristig
deflationäre Kräfte erzeugen kann aber
nach einer Weile eine viel effizientere
Wirtschaft hervorbringen wird
independente Service unabhängige
Beobachter meinten die Binne Nachfrage
müsse durch staatliche Ausgaben
angekurbelt werden dann würde auch die
Kreditnachfrage steigen
wurde der Kate ein Jahrzehnt lang
befolgte die Regierung diesen Rat und
steigerte die Staatsverschuldung auf ein
historisches Niveau
between 19992
zwischen 1992 und 2002 wurden 146
Billionen Yen ausgegeben
er teilt uns jetzt seine Ansichten zur
Entwicklung der japanischen Wirtschaft
mit die Regierung gab mit der rechten
Hand Geld aus indem sie der Wirtschaft
Geld zuführte aber die Mittelbeschaffung
erfolgte über den Anleihe Markt und
deshalb entnahm sie mit der linken Hand
dasselbe Geld aus der Wirtschaft es gab
keinen Anstieg der gesamtkaufkraft
bis 2011 würde Japans Staatsverschuldung
230 Prozent des BIP erreichen die
höchste der Welt
[Musik]
dem Finanzministerium gingen die
Möglichkeiten aus Beobachter begannen
dass Ministerium für die Rezession
verantwortlich zu machen und begannen
auf die Stimmen zu hören die behaupteten
die Rezession sei auf das japanische
Wirtschaftssystem zurückzuführen
aber wie schwierig wäre es gewesen die
Probleme der faulen Kredite im
Bankensektor und der Deflation zu lösen
es stellte sich heraus dass dies gar
nicht so schwierig gewesen wäre das
Finanzsystem ist immer ein Teufelskreis
es gibt kein Kreditwachstum also gibt es
kein Wirtschaftswachstum also gibt es
keinen Kreditwachstum also gibt es kein
Wirtschaftswachstum nun es gibt eine
Sache die dieses zirkuläre Argument
durch Bärchen kann und das ist die
Zentralbank die Aufgabe der Zentralbank
in dieser Situation ist es Geld zu
drucken
was wir jetzt brauchen sind radikalere
Maßnahmen und es gibt einige
schmerzhafte aber es gibt auch
schmerzlose die Zentralbank könnte zum
Beispiel einfach alle faulen Schulden
zum Nennwert aufkaufen Japan hätte dann
die stärksten Banken der Welt
um den Bankensektor zu retten kann eine
Zentralbank die faulen finanzaktiver der
Banken mit neu geschaffenem Geld
aufkaufen und ihnen den Nennwert für die
aktiver geben die auf deutlich weniger
wert sind so hat es die japanische
Zentralbank nach dem Krieg getan
alternate alternativ könnte Geld an die
Banken transferiert werden indem man
ihnen mitteilt große Gewinne zu erzielen
eine Möglichkeit dies zu erreichen
besteht darin dass die Zentralbank einen
Markt in die Enge treibt und so eine
Mini Blase in einem bestimmten
marktschaft in denen die Banken stark
investieren was ihnen große Gewinne
beschertal
Bank dies ist eine relativ gängige
Methode der Zentralbanken um ihren
Bankensystemen zu helfen
andere Vorschläge beinhalten Maßnahmen
zur Einführung von Null
risikokreditnehmern bei Banken oder die
Einführung von Änderungen in der
Rechnungslegung die ihre Bilanzen
verbessern
in Japan in Japan argumentierten die
Behörden und die Zentralbank wie fast
zwei Jahrzehnte später auch die
westlichen Mächte dass der Steuerzahler
die Rechnung bezahlen sollte
[Musik]
wie sie sich vielleicht erinnern hat die
Regierung im März letzten Jahres etwa 15
großen japanischen Finanzinstituten eine
große Summe Geld zugeführt und wir waren
eines von ihnen das hat uns geholfen
faule Kredite abzuschreiben und unsere
Kapitalbasis zu stärken damit wir bereit
sind Kredite zu vergeben
[Musik]
banks Steuergelder wurden zur
Rekapitalisierung von Banken verwendet
es gibt jedoch keine Beweise dafür dass
die Steuerzahler für die Probleme der
Banken verantwortlich waren daher haben
solche Maßnahmen wahrscheinlich ein
moralisches Risiko geschaffen
die Geldmenge wird durch den
Nettozuwachs der Geldschöpfung der
Banken und der Zentralbank bestimmt wenn
das moralische Risiko vorschreibt dass
der Bankensektor nicht gerettet werden
sollte können Deflation und Rezession
von der Zentralbank immer noch vermieden
werden zu diesem Zweck kann die
Zentralbank die Geldmenge erhöhen
das centralbank eine Zentralbank kann
die Geldmenge in einer Volkswirtschaft
jederzeit und unbegrenzt erhöhen indem
sie einfach Vermögenswerte vom privaten
Sektor kauft und mit neu geschaffenen
Krediten bezahlt die Zentralbank hätte
zum Beispiel Immobilien kaufen und in
öffentliche Parks umwandeln können
und hier besteht die Möglichkeit drei
Probleme auf einen Schlag zu lösen die
Wirtschaft braucht Geldschöpfung die
Banken müssen ihre faulen Kredite
loswerden und der Immobiliensektor
braucht einige Transaktionen was man tun
kann ist die Zentralbank Geld drucken zu
lassen denn Banken das Land abzukaufen
es im Parks umzuwandeln und damit auch
ein weiteres Problem zu lösen die
Lebensqualität in Japan
selbst wenn die Zentralbank diese Parks
später zu einem Bruchteil der Kosten
verkauft hätte hätte sie immer noch Geld
verdient weil es eine Zentralbank nichts
kostet das Geld überhaupt erst zu
schaffen eine weitere Möglichkeit Geld
in die Wirtschaft zu pumpen ist die
quantitative Lockerung
bis bald having only option trotz all
dieser Möglichkeiten weigerte sich die
japanische Zentralbank zu jedem
Zeitpunkt Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die die
Krise hätten lösen können
als ich 1992
1993 als Gastwissenschaftler bei der
japanischen Zentralbank war war ich
davon überzeugt dass diese Rezession
wirklich schlimm werden würde also
fragte ich jeden Mitarbeiter der
japanischen Zentralbank der mit mir
sprechen wollte warum sie nicht mehr
Geld drucken ich traf eine Person die
sehr offen darüber sprach und sie sagte
Richard natürlich hätten wir mehr Geld
drucken können wir hätten einen
Aufschwung herbeiführen können aber dann
hätte sich nichts geändert die
Wirtschaftsstruktur hätte sich nicht
verändert damals war ich noch nicht
bereit zu glauben dass die Zentralbank
die Rezession ernsthaft in die Länge zog
um strukturelle Veränderungen zu
erreichen die mir ein wenig zu wild
erschienen
[Musik]
Finanzminister Masa juroshiokava hat
sich an die Zentralbank gewarnt und sie
gebeten die Deflation zu stoppen oder
zumindest zu bekämpfen the Bank of Japan
die Zentralbank widersetzte sich
konsequent in Aufforderungen der
Regierung das Finanzministers und des
Premierministers mehr Geld zu drucken um
die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln und die lange
Rezession zu beenden
at times zeitweise reduzierte die
japanische Zentralbank sogar aktiv die
in der Wirtschaft zirkulierende
Geldmenge was die Rezession noch
verschlimmerte
[Musik]
Pants die Argumente der japanischen
Zentralbank waren immer die gleichen
nämlich dass die Schuld in der
Wirtschaftsstruktur Japans liegt
centralbank Mitarbeiter der Zentralbank
argumentierten sogar dass eine
erhebliche geldpolitische Lockerung
Schaden anrichten könnte indem sie eine
weitere Verzögerung des Fortschritts der
strukturellen Anpassung bewirke
heißt wo Japanese die früheren
japanischen Führer danach Kriegszeit
wussten dass sie eine Kriegswirtschaft
betrieben aber sie wollten aus
politischen Gründen nicht darüber
sprechen
die propaganda-botschaft des Kalten
Krieges lautete dass das Japan der
Nachkriegszeit ein politisches und
wirtschaftliches System nach
amerikanischem Vorbild übernommen hatte
an willing to till the truth dass sie
nicht bereit waren die Wahrheit zu sagen
Name die frühe nachkriegsführer ihr
intimes Wissen über die Ursprünge von
Japans Wirtschaftswunder mit ins Grab in
den 1980er und 1990er Jahren herrschte
eine Generation von Bürokraten und
Politikern die den wahren Charakter und
Zweck der Wirtschaft ihres Landes nicht
verstanden
[Musik]
eine ganze Generation japanischer
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler wurde in die
Vereinigten Staaten geschickt um dort
einen Doktor Titel und einen
MBA-Abschluss in
Wirtschaftswissenschaften nach
amerikanischen Vorbild zu erwerben sind
Nähe Klassik da die Neo klassische
Wirtschaftswissenschaft davon ausgeht
dass es nur eine Art von
Wirtschaftssystem gibt nämlich
uneingeschränkte freie Märkte in denen
Aktionäre und Zentralbanker das Sagen
haben haben viele japanische
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler schnell die
Argumente der US-amerikanischen
Wirtschaft zu Wissenschaftler
nachgeplappert
[Musik]
die USA und Japan haben am Dienstag
zweitägige Gespräche über
versicherungsregulierungen abgeschlossen
die Deregulierung des primärsektors ist
notwendig um die festgefahrenen
Interessen der großen
Versicherungsgesellschaften sowohl der
Lebens als auch Sachversicherer und die
Bürokratie des Finanzministeriums zu
überwinden
sie müssen vor dem 15 Dezember eine
Einigung erzielen denn nach diesem Datum
haben die USA mit Handelssanktionen
gedroht ein wichtiger Schritt den
Analysten erwarten ist die Verbriefung
von Immobilien aber wird das Paket
ausreichen mehr dazu im Gespräch mit
Richard Werner um eine sinnvolle
Verbriefung zu erreichen brauchen wir
eine Deregulierung und das ist bereits
die Antwort auf Ihre Frage um eine
Deregulierung zu erreichen müssen sie
die Macht des Finanzministeriums
beschneiden und offensichtlich hat sich
das Ministerium dem widersetzt in the
1980er Jahren wurden Personen die sich
mit einer Visitenkarte des renommierten
Finanzministeriums vorstellen konnten
verehrt und respektiert
doch Mitte der 1990er Jahre hatte sich
die Einstellung geändert und für die
meisten Beobachter gab es kaum noch
Zweifel daran dass das Finanzministerium
die Rezession verursacht hatte
Ministeriums
vor den Toren des Ministeriums kam es
häufig zu Demonstrationen von Bürgern
die über die Handlungen der Bürokraten
empört waren
in early 99 Anfang 1998 führte die
Staatsanwaltschaft zum ersten Mal eine
Razzia im mächtigsten japanischen
Ministerium durch
sowohl die Banken als auch ihre
Aufsichtsbehörden wurden für ihr
Vorgehen heftig kritisiert die Skandale
warfen ein Schlaglicht auf einige der
informellen Verbindungen die zwischen
Beamten des Finanzministeriums und
Bankern bestanden viele Bankangestellte
und sogar einige ministerial Beamte
wurden verhaftet und ins Gefängnis
gesteckt und mehrere begingen Selbstmord
wieder Zentralbank
erklärt hatte es ist nicht einfach den
institutionellen Rahmen zu ändern und
strukturelle Reformen zu fördern da dies
notwendigerweise die Interessen aller
Beteiligten Wirtschaftsakteure berührt
ein stellvertretender Gouverneur der
japanischen Zentralbank sagte dass die
Zentralbank vor dem großen Dilemma steht
dass die Lockerung der Geldpolitik zu
einer Abschwächung der unmittelbaren
Risiken führen würde was wiederum eine
Verzögerung der endgültigen Lösungen zur
Folge hätte
ab Mitte der 1990er Jahre begann die
Regierung einen Großteil der
Machtstruktur des Finanzministeriums
abzubauen die Zentralbank hingegen
konnte ihren Einfluss erheblich ausbauen
sie haben erst kürzlich geschrieben sie
haben keinen Zweifel daran dass die
Zentralbank die japanische Zentralbank
vom Finanzministerium losgelöst und
unabhängig werden wird so dass sie mit
anderen Zentralbanken gleichgestellt
wird warum sind Sie so sicher
im Grunde genommen hat das
Finanzministerium das zumindest die
Zentralbank rechtlich kontrollierte jede
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren das
Finanzministerium wird für die
Entstehung der Blase für die lange
Rezession und für viele andere Probleme
die wir in letzter Zeit in Japan hatten
verantwortlich gemacht die japanische
Zentralbank entgegenstand nicht im
Rampenlicht der öffentlichen Kritik und
nutzt dies nun um zu sagen nun das
Finanzministerium war schlecht wir
brauchen jetzt Unabhängigkeit
Richard vielen Dank ich habe mit Richard
Werner gesprochen dem Chef Volkswirt von
TAD in flaming Securitys in Tokio
kurz nach seinem ausschalten aus dem Amt
des Gouverneurs der japanischen
Zentralbank im Jahr 1994 begann mienu
eine Kampagne mit Reden vor
verschiedenen Verbänden und
Interessensgruppen er setzte sich für
eine Änderung des Gesetzes über die
Zentralbank ein
Hitler seine Argumentation bestand darin
auf subtile Weise anzudeuten dass das
Finanzministerium die japanische
Zentralbank zu einer falschen Politik
gedrängt hatte um solche Probleme in
Zukunft zu vermeiden müsste der
japanischen Zentralbank volle rechtliche
Unabhängigkeit gewährt werden
die Unabhängigkeit der Zentralbanken
sowie jeno entspreche der menschlichen
Weisheit die sich in der Geschichte
entwickelt habe im Jahr 1998 wurde die
Geldpolitik in die Hände der nun
unabhängigen japanischen Zentralbank
gelegt
sie sagen also dass sowohl Politiker als
auch Ökonomen mehr Druck auf die
japanische Zentralbank ausüben sollten
mehr Geld zu schaffen aber viele
Kritiker werden sagen dass das ein
Eingriff in die Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbank ist was halten Sie davon
das ist genau richtig das ist ein
Eingriff in die Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbanken und das ist genau das was
wir brauchen
[Musik]
zahlreichen Skandale die auf das Platzen
der Blase folgten brachten 1995 auch das
System der Einparteienherrschaft der
liberaldemokratischen Partei zu Fall
in News System im alten System
konkurrierten die Politiker nicht
miteinander indem sie unterschiedlich
politikstile vorschlagen die Politik
wurde von den Bürokraten gemacht und die
Politiker konzentrierten sich lediglich
darauf lokale Wählerschaften mit
öffentlichen Bauprojekten zu
beschwichtigen
im Oktober 1997 gingen zum ersten Mal in
der Nachkriegsgeschichte alle
politischen Initiativen zur ankupplung
der Wirtschaft von Politikern und nicht
von Bürokraten aus
wenn in Reli 2011 Anfang 2001 wurde dann
ein neuer Typ Politiker an die Macht
gebracht
Minister Youtube wurde Premierminister
in Bezug auf seine Popularität und seine
Politik wird er oft mit Margaret
Thatcher und Ronald Reagan verglichen
seine Botschaft war einfach kein
Aufschwung ohne Strukturreformen
[Musik]
auf dem Genfer Gipfel im Juli 2001 sagte
er manche sagen der Aufschwung kommt
zuerst ohne Reformen aber sobald sich
die Wirtschaft erholt schwindet der
Wille zu Reformen deshalb werde ich nach
den Wahlen an den Plan festhalten dass
es ohne Strukturreformen kein Wachstum
geben wird
one im Laufe des Jahres 2001 wurde die
Botschaft dass es ohne Strukturreformen
kein Wirtschaftswachstum gibt fast
täglich über die Fernsehbildschirme der
Nation verbreitet
gibt es sieben Druck auf Japan aus
Strukturreformen durchzuführen in Korea
gab es Unruhen aber dann beschloss die
Regierung große Konglomerate zu
zerschlagen
jetzt erholt sich die Wirtschaft des
Landes nun ist es an der Zeit das
japanstrukturreform durchführt
[Musik]
jetzt glaubt jeder dass wir strukturelle
Veränderungen brauchen dass wir den
Kapitalismus japanischer Prägung
abschaffen müssen um einen Aufschwung zu
erreichen es scheint dass wir alles
ausprobiert haben und nichts hat
funktioniert also muss das japanische
Wirtschaftssystem schuld sein daher
sollten wir es besser loswerden
[Musik]
Japan bis shifting ins economic system
Japan stellte sein Wirtschaftssystem auf
eine Marktwirtschaft nach amerikanischem
Vorbild um und das bedeutet auch dass
das Zentrum der Wirtschaft von den
Banken auf die Aktienmärkte verlagert
wurde
Twin ties the positive um Einleger dazu
zu bewegen ihr Geld von den Banken
abzuziehen und in den riskanten
Aktienmarkt zu investieren hoben die
Reformer die Garantie für alle
Bankeinlagen auf und schufen
gleichzeitig steuerliche Anreize für
aktieninvestitionen
mit der Ausbreitung des Shareholder
Kapitalismus nach amerikanischem Vorbild
stiegen die Arbeitslosigkeit die
Einkommens und vermögensunterschiede
sowie Selbstmorde und Gewaltverbrechen
erheblich an
wenn du im Jahr 2002 verstärkte die
japanische Zentralbank an ihre
Bemühungen die Bankbilanzen zu
verschlechtern und die Banken zu zwingen
ihre Kreditnehmer Zwang zu vollstrecken
bis dahin hat er sich Hako war Minister
für Finanzdienstleistungen gegen den von
der japanischen Zentralbank inspirierten
Vorschlag gewehrt den Banken
Steuergelder zuzuführen sie faktisch zu
verständlichen ihre Verwaltung zu
übernehmen und diese Macht zu nutzen um
Kredite von Unternehmen einzufordern was
zu zahlreichen Insolvenzen von
Großunternehmen führte
müsste Jannika sauer jana gisawa wurde
daraufhin vom Premierminister entlassen
und durch hesetacke Naka ersetzt
takenaka war ein Befürworter des Plans
der japanischen Zentralbank die Zahl der
Zwangsvollstreckungen von Kreditnehmern
zu erhöhen
eine Politik umzusetzen die die Bilanzen
der Banken drastisch schwächte um sie
verstaatlichen zu können
zur Überwachung der bankenpolitik der
zwei ehemalige Mitarbeiter der
japanischen Zentralbank angehörten einer
von ihnen Takeshi Kimura forderte sofort
die Einführung von Änderungen in der
Rechnungslegung die die Bilanzen der
Banken verschlechtern und eine
Verstaatlichung unumgänglich machen
würden
ein Bekannter Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
Tokio argumentierte eindringlich dass
der von der japanischen Zentralbank
inspirierte Vorschlag von takenaka nicht
viele Einheimische Nutznießer hätte
sondern stattdessen vor allem
US-amerikanischen geierfonds so Gute
käme die auf den Aufkauf notleidender
Vermögenswerte spezialisiert sind
waren mit dem Problem konfrontiert dass
trotz über 200.000 Konkursen nur wenige
Unternehmen die groß genug waren um für
die geierfonds von Interesse zu sein
bankrottgingen
ihre Unterstützung für den Insolvenzplan
bekundeten leitete ersterer ein privates
Unternehmen das bei der Verbriefung von
notleidenden Vermögenswerten berät und
letzterer war Berater der Wall Street
Investmentfirma Goldman Sachs einem der
größten Betreiber von Geier Fonds
weltweit
und sein Mentor Herr mai Cover sie ahnen
es das sind einige der Prinzen des Yen
um die es in dem Buch geht sie haben in
den 80er Jahren und auch in den 90er
Jahren immer wieder gesagt was ist das
Ziel der Geldpolitik es ist die
Wirtschaftsstruktur zu verändern und wie
stellt man das an nun man braucht eine
Krise und genau dafür haben sie gesagt
wir haben keine Zeit mehr ich muss Sie
leider unterbrechen ich arbeite für eine
der großen stadtbanken ich war früher
für die Kreditvergabe an die japanische
Zentralbank zuständig während der Bubble
Ära wurde uns von der japanischen
Zentralbank alle drei Monate mitgeteilt
um wie viel die Kredite erhöht werden
mussten die Zuteilung der Windows der
japanischen Zentralbank war ein Befehl
die Ursache der Blase war die Windows
und sie wurde auf Anweisung der
japanischen Zentralbank durchgeführt
die Abteilung die bei der japanischen
Zentralbank für die Quoten für die
Windows zuständig war hieß Banking
Department und wer war der
Verantwortliche dafür der Mann an der
Spitze dieser bankabteilung während der
Blase von 86 bis 89 war toshii der
derzeitige Gouverneur der japanischen
Zentralbank ist der Mann der die Blase
geschaffen hat
der japanischen Zentralbank wurde sagte
er während das starke Wachstumsmodell
zerstört wird baue ich ein Modell auf
das in die neue Ära passt
wir haben in jeder Hinsicht Erfolg
gehabt wenn man sich die Liste ihrer
Ziele anschaut haben sie alle diese
Ziele erreicht das Finanzministerium
zerstören es auflösen eine unabhängige
Aufsichtsbehörde einrichten die
Unabhängigkeit der japanischen
Zentralbank selbst durch eine Änderung
des japanischen zentralbankgesetzes
erreichen und tiefgreifende strukturelle
Veränderungen in der Wirtschaft
herbeiführen indem sie sich von der
Produktion auf Dienstleistungen
verlagern sich öffnen der regulieren
liberalisieren privatisieren all das
in the 1920 in den 1920er Jahren ähnelte
japans Wirtschaft in vielerlei Hinsicht
der heutigen US-Wirtschaft mit hartem
Wettbewerb aggressiven Einstellungen und
Entlassungen Übernahme Schlachten
zwischen großen Unternehmen wenigen
bürokratischen Kontrollen starken
Aktionären die hohe Dividenden forderten
und einer Unternehmensfinanzierung durch
die Märkte nicht durch die Banken
während der gesamten Nachkriegszeit war
japans Wirtschaft jedoch das Gegenteil
stark reguliert mit Kartellen die den
Wettbewerb einschränken Bank
Finanzierung und über kreuzbeteiligungen
die die Macht der Aktionäre
einschränkten keine übernahmen und ein
eingefrorener Arbeitsmarkt mit
lebenslanger Beschäftigung und
dienstaltersvergütung
es wurde behauptet dass Japan um die
Rezession zu beenden und die Leistung zu
verbessern vom wohlfahrtskapitalismus
zurück zum shareholder Kapitalismus
wechseln müsste es bleibt jedoch unklar
warum ein Land das einen beständ igen
und erheblichen Handelsbilanzüberschuss
erzielt hat sein Wirtschaftssystem
ändern muss um wettbewerbsfähiger zu
sein
economy in Japan war nicht die einzige
leistungsstarke Volkswirtschaft in Asien
die in den 1990er Jahren in die tiefste
Rezession seit der Großen Depression
geredet
in 997 im Jahr 1997 konnten die
Währungen der südostasiatischen
Tigerstaaten keinen festen Wechselkurs
zum US-Dollar aufrecht erhalten sie
brachen innerhalb eines Jahres um 60 bis
80% ein
the coses with die Ursachen für diesen
Absturz reichen bis in das Jahr 1993
zurück in jenem Jahr führten die
asiatischen Tigerstaaten Südkorea
Thailand und Indonesien eine aggressive
lockerungspolitik im Kapitalverkehr und
internationale Bankdienstleistungen ein
die ist im Unternehmens und Bankensektor
ermöglichten großzügig Kredite im
Ausland aufzunehmen es war das erste Mal
in der Nachkriegszeit das Kreditnehmer
dies tun konnten
in reality in Wirklichkeit bestand für
die asiatischen Tigerstaaten keine
Notwendigkeit sich Geld im Ausland zu
leihen das gesamte für inländische
Investitionen erforderliche Geld konnte
im eigenen Land geschaffen werden der
Druck zur Liberalisierung der
Kapitalströme kam in der Tat von außen
seit Anfang der 1990er Jahre hatten der
IWF die Welthandelsorganisation und das
US-Finanzministerium Lobbyarbeit in
diesen Ländern betrieben um inländischen
Unternehmen die Kreditaufnahme im
Ausland zu ermöglichen sie
argumentierten dass die neoklassische
Wirtschaftslehre bewiesen habe das freie
Märkte und freier Kapitalverkehr das
Wirtschaftswachstum steigern sind
die regulated nach der die Regulierung
der Kapital konnten machten sich die
Zentralbanken daran unwiderstehliche
Anreize für inländische Unternehmen zu
schaffen Kredite im Ausland aufzunehmen
sie verteuerten die Kreditaufnahme in
der eigenen Landeswährung gegenüber der
Kreditaufnahme in USA
die inländischen Zinssätze waren hoch
sie waren höher als die Zinssätze des
US-Dollars und der Wechselkurs war
praktisch
fixed es waren die Regierung und die
Zentralbank die gesagt haben wir werden
den Wechselkurs beibehalten das stimmt
die Zentralbanken Thailands und andere
ostasiatischer Länder wieder setzten
sich der wechselkursanpassung und
versuchten ein Zeichen dafür zu setzen
den Wechselkurs schützen zu wollen
[Musik]
in der public statements die
Zentralbanken betonten in ihren
öffentlichen Erklärungen dass sie feste
Wechselkurse zum US-Dollar beibehalten
würden sodass die Kreditnehmer nicht
befürchten mussten in ihrer
Landeswährung mehr zurückzuzahlen als
ursprünglich aufgenommen hatten
Mission als externer Berater ging nicht
direkt zur Bank von Thailand und fragte
gibt es hier irgendwelche informellen
Kreditrichtlinien sie waren überrascht
dass sich diese Frage stellte aufgrund
meines Studiums in Japan dachte ich dass
es vielleicht etwas ähnliches gäbe und
es war ein junger Mitarbeiter der sich
vielleicht der politischen Zusammenhänge
nicht bewusst war der sagte ja ja wir
haben so einen kreditplanungsschema
die Banken wurden angewiesen die
Kreditvergabe zu erhöhen sie sahen sich
jedoch mit einer geringeren
Kreditnachfrage aus den produktiven
Sektoren der Wirtschaft konfrontiert da
diese Unternehmen Anreize erhalten
hatten lieber Kredite im Ausland
aufzunehmen sie mussten daher ihre
Kreditvergabe auf risikoreichere
Kreditnehmer ausweiten
imports beginnt die Importe begannen zu
schrumpfen weil die Zentralbanken
vereinbart hatten ihre Währungen an den
US-Dollar zu binden economies
die Volkswirtschaften wurden weniger
wettbewerbsfähig aber ihre
Leistungsbilanz blieb aufgrund der im
Ausland ausgegebenen Kredite die in der
zahlungsbilanzstatistik als Exporte
zählen stabil
Prinz
Spekulanten damit begannen den
thailändischen Bart den koreanischen
wohnen und die indonesische Rupie zu
verkaufen reagierten die jeweiligen
Zentralbanken mit vergeblichen Versuchen
die Bindung aufrecht zu erhalten bis Sie
praktisch ihre gesamten Devisenreserven
aufgebraucht hatten
dies gab ausländischen Kreditgebern
reichlich Gelegenheit ihr Geld zu
überhöhten Wechselkursen abzuziehen
das central banks die Zentralbanken
wussten dass sie wenn den Ländern die
Devisen Reserven ausgingen den IWF
Einschalten mussten um einen
Zahlungsausfall zu vermeiden und wenn
der IWF erst einmal da war wussten die
Zentralbanken was diese in Washington
ansässige Institution verlangen würde
denn ihre Forderungen waren in solchen
Fällen in den vergangenen drei
Jahrzehnten immer die gleichen die
Zentralbanken sollten unabhängig werden
am 16 juli flog der thailändische
Finanzminister nach Tokio um Japan um
ein Rettungspaket zu bitten
damals verfügte Japan über die
wiesenreserven in Höhe von 213
Milliarden US-Dollar mehr als die
gesamten Mittel des IWF
man war bereit zu helfen aber Washington
stoppte die Initiative Japans jede
Lösung für die sich entwickelnde
Asienkrise musste von Washington über
den IWF kommen
nach zwei Monaten spekulativer Angriffe
hat die thailändische Regierung den Bart
freigegeben
der Internationale Währungsfonds hat den
angeschlagenen Volkswirtschaften von
Thailand Indonesien und Südkorea bisher
fast 120 Milliarden Dollar zugesagt im
mediat unmittelbar nach ihrer Ankunft in
den Krisen geschüttelten Ländern
richteten die iwf-teams Büros in den
Zentralbanken ein von wo aus sie regeln
Vorgaben die sich wie eine
kapitulationsforderung anhörten
eine Reihe von Maßnahmen darunter die
Einschränkung der Kreditvergabe durch
die Zentralbank und die Banken
umfangreicher Gesetzesänderungen und
eine drastische Anhebung der Zinssätze
also interest als die Zinssätze stiegen
konnten erste risikoreiche Kreditnehmer
ihre Darlehen nicht mehr bedienen die
Bankensysteme Thailands Koreas und
Indonesiens die mit großen Mengen
uneindringlicher Forderungen belastet
waren waren praktisch bankrott
selbst ansonsten gesunde Unternehmen
begannen unter der sich ausweitenden
Kreditklemme zu leiten die
Unternehmensinsolvenzen stiegen
sprunghaft an die Arbeitslosigkeit stieg
auf den höchsten Stand seit den 1930er
Jahren
die Rolle des Fonds bei der Rettung
angeschlagener Länder ist heftig
umstritten einige haben den IWF sogar
beschuldigt die Wirtschaftskrise in
Asien zu verschärfen selbst wenn Sie
unsere Wirtschaft untergraben müssen
werden sie das tun nur um zu beweisen
dass Sie im Recht sind die EWF war keine
große Hilfe
der IWF wusste genau welche Folgen sein
Vorgehen haben würde im Falle Koreas
wurden sogar detaillierte aber nicht
veröffentlichte Studien durchgeführt in
denen berechnet wurde wie viele
koreanische Unternehmen bankrott gehen
würden wenn die Zinssätze um 5% Punkte
stiegen
das erste Abkommen des IWF mit Korea
verlangte eine Erhöhung der Zinssätze um
genau fünf Prozentpunkte
die Politik des IWF zielt eindeutig
nicht darauf ab einen wirtschaftlichen
Aufschwung in den asiatischen Ländern zu
erreichen sie verfolgen eine ganz andere
Agenda nämlich die Veränderung der
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
sozialen Systemen in diesen Ländern und
wirklich die iwf-geschäfte verhindern
dass die betroffenen Länder wie Korea
und Thailand einen Aufschwung erleben
interessant sie sagen dass es die Krisen
verschlimmerer und sie behaupten dass
die IWF eine heimliche Agenda habe diese
Agenda ist kein Geheimnis denn der IWF
verlangt ganz offen dass die Betroffenen
asiatischen Länder die Gesetze ändern
damit ausländische Interessenten alles
kaufen können von Banken bis zu Land und
in der Tat können die Bankensysteme laut
iwf-deal nur mit ausländischen Geld ihr
Kapital erhöhen dabei ist das gar nicht
notwendig denn solange diese Länder
Zentralbanken haben können Sie einfach
Geld drucken und die Bankensysteme
rekapitalisieren dafür braucht man kein
Geld aus dem Ausland es geht also
eindeutig darum Asien für ausländische
Interessenten zu öffnen
nicht gerettet sondern geschlossen und
als notleidende aktiver billig verkauft
werden häufig an große
US-Investmentbanken
eine gute Nachricht aus Thailand ist
dass sie einige große Vermögenswerte von
56 Finanzunternehmen versteigern werden
sollten ihrer Meinung nach einige der
Eigentümer der 56 Finanzunternehmen die
Möglichkeit haben ihre Vermögenswerte
zurückzukaufen
in most cases in den meisten Fällen
wurde in den vom IWF diktierten
Absichtserklärungen ausdrücklich
festgelegt dass die Banken ein
ausländische Investoren verkauft werden
mussten
und lassen Sie mich in dieser Hinsicht
betonen dass diese Reformprogramme der
Schlüssel der absolute Schlüssel zur
Wiederherstellung der finanziellen
Stabilität sind
zum ersten Mal überhaupt hat Südkorea
fünf Banken geschlossen und damit einen
wichtigen Schritt zur Erfüllung des
iwf-mandats getan
die Zahl der Geschäftsbanken ist
zurückgegangen durch Schließungen
Fusionen und Übernahmen und ausländische
strategische Investoren mischen jetzt
mit was eine bemerkenswerte Veränderung
ist
in Asien waren staatlich organisierte
Rettungsaktionen zur Rettung maroder
Finanzinstitute untersagt doch als ein
Jahr später eine ähnliche Krise in
Amerika aus brach reagierten dieselben
Institute anders
Long Term Capital Management der nur
vermögende Privatanleger und
Institutionen als Kunden akzeptierte
hatte seinen kundenkapital von 5
Milliarden Dollar um mehr als das
25-fache gehebelt und sich dafür von den
Banken dieser Welt mehr als 100
Milliarden Dollar geliehen
als ihre Verluste die Banken mit
runterzuziehen drohten die ihr Kredite
gewährt hatten und eine systemische
Bankenkrise drohte die das US
Finanzsystem und die US-Wirtschaft
gefährden konnte organisierte die
Federal Reserve eine Kartell ähnliche
Rettungsaktion indem sie sich auf die
Wall Street und internationale Banken
stürzte um Mittel bei zu steuern mit
denen ein Zahlungsausfall vermieden
werden konnte
sie haben Recht Washington und New York
Schienen damit zweierlei Master messen
kurz nachdem sie allen asiatischen
Ländern gesagt hatten dass es keine
Rettungsaktionen für Finanzinstitutionen
geben würde wurde für Long Term Capital
Management ein Hedgefond New York der
fast pleite ging plötzlich eine
Rettungsaktion organisiert was im
Widerspruch zu dem stand was sie den
asiatischen Ländern gerade erst gesagt
hatten aber sie sagten dass keine
öffentlichen Gelder für LTCM verwendet
wurden aber das Treffen fand bekanntlich
innerhalb der Federal Reserve statt
United States warum sollten die
Vereinigten Staaten im Namen des freien
Marktes Forderungen an fremde Nationen
stellen wenn sie nicht die Absicht haben
dieselben Regeln innerhalb ihrer eigenen
Grenzen durchzusetzen die Beispiele der
japanischen und der asiatischen Krise
zeigen wie Krisen konstruiert werden
können um die Umverteilung von
wirtschaftlichem Eigentum zu erleichtern
und rechtliche strukturelle und
politische Veränderungen durchzusetzen
heute sind ähnliche Ereignisse in der
Eurozone zu beobachten
die Länder des euro-währungsblocks haben
ihr Recht auf eine nationale Währung
verloren und die Macht an die
Europäische Zentralbank abgegeben bei
mir hier im Studio ist Richard Werner er
ist Professor an der universitätshaus
Hampton Richard war Berater der
japanischen Zentralbank und des
Finanzministeriums am Ende der
bubblehrer in den 90er Jahren was raten
sie der EZB die morgen Tag was würden
Sie Ihr sagen
nun auch hier sollte sie sich mehr auf
das Kreditvolumen als auf die Zinssätze
konzentrieren die EZB muss aus ihren
Fehlern der Vergangenheit lernen denn
ich glaube sie hat die Kreditschöpfung
nicht sorgfältig genug überwacht in
Spanien und Irland hatten wir unter der
Aufsicht der EZB eine massive
Kreditausweitung der Leitzins in der
Eurozone ist natürlich überall gleich
aber das Volumen der Kredite ist sehr
unterschiedlich es gibt einen
einheitlichen Zinssatz für die gesamte
Eurozone aber 2002 wie ist die EZB die
Deutsche Bundesbank an ihre
Kreditschöpfung und den größten Betrag
in ihrer Geschichte zu reduzieren und
sie liest die IR ische Zentralbank an
Geld zu drucken als gäbe es keinen
Morgen
was wird nun also kommen gleicher
Leitzins gleiches Wachstum nein
Rezession in Deutschland Aufschwung in
Irland was sagt Ihnen das welche
Variable Kreditschöpfung
vor ab 2004 stiegen unter der Aufsicht
der EZB die Bankkredite in Irland
Griechenland Portugal und Spanien um
über 20% pro Jahr an und die
Immobilienpreise schossen in die Höhe
als die Bankkredite zurückgingen brachen
die mobilen Preise ein Bauträger gingen
pleite und die Bankensysteme von Irland
Portugal Spanien und Griechenland wurden
zahlungsunfähig Island
the easybd hätte diese Blasen verhindern
können ebenso wie sie die
darauffolgenden Banken und
Wirtschaftskrisen hätte beenden können
doch sie weigerte sich dies zu tun bevor
nicht größere politische Zugeständnisse
gemacht wurden wie beispielsweise die
Übertragung der Steuer und
haushaltsbefugnisse von den einzelnen
souveränen Staaten auf die Europäische
Union
grease sowohl in Spanien als auch in
Griechenland ist die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit auf 50% gestiegen
so dass viele Jugendliche gezwungen sind
sich im Ausland Arbeit zu suchen
griechische Ärzte für deren Ausbildung
die griechischen Steuerzahler bezahlt
haben arbeiten jetzt in Deutschland
Beratungen der beschlussorgane der EZB
sind geheim der bloße Versuch einer
Einflussnahme auf die EZB etwa durch
demokratische Debatten und Diskussionen
ist nach dem Vertrag von Maastricht
untersagt die EZB ist eine
internationale Organisation die über den
Gesetzen und Zuständigkeiten der
einzelnen Staaten steht ihre leitenden
Mitarbeiter tragen die tomatenpässe und
die Akten und Dokumente innerhalb der
Europäischen Zentralbank können von
keiner Polizeibehörde oder
Staatsanwaltschaft durchsucht oder
beschlagnahmt werden
als eine der mächtigsten und
intransparentesten Zentralbanken der
Welt bekannt doch ihr ehemaliger
Präsident Jean-Claude trèse begegnete
diesem Problem mit der bloßen Behauptung
es gebe kein Problem
[Musik]
die EZB ist eine der transparentesten
Zentralbanken der Welt und hat dazu
beigetragen den Stand der Technik im
zentralbankwesen in diesem Bereich zu
definieren behauptete er
Weltwirtschaftsforum Davos Schweiz
mein Name ist Richard Werner ich bin
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler meine Frage
richtet sich an Herrn Trichet die Frage
ist wo im Vertrag von Maastricht oder in
den ezb-statuten steht das ist die
Aufgabe der EZB ist Strukturreformen
oder eine andere politische Agenda zu
unterstützen
ich habe sehr sehr deutlich gesagt und
wir haben immer wieder sehr sehr
deutlich gesagt dass wir in diesem
Bereich keine Verantwortung tragen wir
haben eine Meinung und wir sagen was wir
denken und wenn wir dadurch dazu
beitragen können den Menschen von
unserer Seite aus zu erklären dass es
ihnen besser gehen könnte dann würde das
vielleicht Europa dabei helfen mit der
Umsetzung von Strukturreformen zu
beginnen die so wichtig sind und darüber
gibt es einen Konsens einen sehr sehr
großen Konsens in diesem Punkt
ist
very very very Lodge konzentrismus
[Musik]
die Europäische Kommission eine nicht
gewählte Interessensgruppe deren Ziel es
ist Vereinigte Staaten von Europa mit
allen Merkmalen eines Einheitsstaates zu
erschaffen hat ein Interesse daran die
einzelnen Regierungen und den Einfluss
der demokratischen Parlamente Europas zu
schwächen
[Musik]
wie sich herausstellte stammten die
Beweise für die Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbanken auf die sich der Vertrag
von Maastricht stützte aus einer
einzigen Studie die von niemand anderem
als der Europäischen Kommission selbst
in Auftrag gegeben worden war
andere Name die 1992 unter dem Titel ein
Markt eine Währung veröffentlichte
Studie behauptete zu beweisen dass die
Unabhängigkeit der Zentralbanken zu
einer niedrigen Inflation führt James
oder James forder ein Wissenschaftler
aus Oxford hat inzwischen nachgewiesen
dass diese Studie manipuliert wurde um
das gewünschte Ergebnis zu erreichen
die Geschichte die uns von der
Zentralbanken erzählt wird ist
widersprüchlich und es gibt Beweise
dafür dass die Zentralbanken anders
arbeiten als sie uns glauben machen
wollen
auf der ganzen Welt haben die
Zentralbanken bedeutende aber wenig
bekannte Befugnisse oft unabhängig nicht
rechenschaftspflichtig und
undurchsichtig agieren Zentralbanken im
Verborgenen doch ihr Handeln betrifft
uns alle
centralbanks die Zentralbanken in fast
allen Ländern der Welt und der IWF hat
einiges dazu beigetragen sind völlig
unabhängig geworden und praktisch keiner
demokratischen Institution gegenüber
rechenschaftspflichtig selbst die
Rechenschaftspflicht gegenüber dem
Parlament ist in der Regel gering und in
der Praxis bedeutungslos
um die japanische Zentralbank die
Federal Reserve die Bank of England oder
die Europäische Zentralbank handelt
Beispiele für den Betrug der
Zentralbanken gibt es viele in den
Vereinigten Staaten wurden die Banken in
den 1920er Jahren ermutigt Geld zu
schaffen und es an Spekulanten zu geben
die daraus resultierende Depression
überzeugte die freiheitsliebenden
Amerikaner davon dass ein
dezentralisiertes föderales System ohne
starke nationale Kontrolle nicht
funktionieren konnte
[Musik]
in den 1990er Jahren wurden die Japaner
davon überzeugt dass ihr
Wirtschaftssystem das beträchtlichen
Wohlstand und Gleichheit gebracht hatte
in ein sogenanntes System der freien
Marktwirtschaft umgewandelt werden müsse
Transformation Japans Transformation war
noch nicht vollständig abgeschlossen da
schlugen die Zentralbanker erneut zu und
zwar mit einem vom IWF angeführten
Überfall auf die Volkswirtschaften der
asiatischen Tigerstaaten
the present die gegenwärtige europäische
Schuldenkrise ist ein weiteres Beispiel
für die Täuschung der Zentralbanken
the create public imces einen
öffentlichen Konsens für die
Notwendigkeit von Strukturreformen zu
schaffen indem man absichtlich eine
Rezession herbeiführt und sie dann
unnötig verlängert stellt einen
Machtmissbrauch dar
ins wollen die Bürger wirklich auf so
kostspielige und unehrliche Weise
manipuliert werden
[Musik]
nach dem Buch Prinzen von Professor
Richard Werner
[Musik]